now joined by the coach of the Los
Angeles Lakers Darin have
congratulations coach thanks for having
me man appreciate that thank
you youry that's I got to give you the
question you got to go first the
question first of all from the great
state of
Michigan you know I want to start off
you know obviously players play great
games absolutely but the scheme and the
game plan oh the double team and just
the little things even when they try to
seek out D'Angelo Russell you still
double team and obviously you know
Tyrese Halbert is that type of talent
where you wanted to get the ball out of
his hand absolutely man we came into it
we met this morning we have been talking
about it for a couple of days now once
we you know saw that we were going to be
playing them um and we just want the air
on the side of aggression just be
aggressive and it's twofold right one
trying to slow him down but two
activating our defense everybody behind
them you have to be on our high alert
when you're blitzing and double team and
certain players so it helped us it it
just woke everybody's hands and feet up
and we're moving around man we we we had
some beautiful deal I can't wait to go
back and show this film to the team and
just how we can be on a consistent basis
what was your message to Anthony Davis
before this game hey man just set the
tone on both sides of the ball set the
tone and he's great he allows the game
to come to him I know he takes a lot of
flack because he's not more aggressive
or assertive offensively he's just like
similar to Bri a God has just tries to
make the right Play and play the right
way and for him you know if if Brun is
our Tom Brady on on on offense Anthony
Davis is our Ray Lewis he anchors our
defense he plays middle linebacker he
communicates he does all of that he
covers up for the mistakes and he allows
for our uh perimeter Defenders the Toran
princes the cam reddish the max
Christies the Vos all those guys just
turn them loose on the perimeter and be
in passing lanes and be aggressive on
the ball so they know he's got their
back you know Darin we know the
greatness of LeBron James he's a
tournament MVP but there was something
different when he got to Vegas the look
in his eye to him running taking charges
tell me what you saw from LeBron James
that was a little bit different than
before and he he looked like a guy that
was uh campaign and to have his own team
here and probably he going to make a
deal where he starts off as the player
owner have we ever had a player owner
before we had player coach player
coaches not a player owner he he could
be the first again that's something but
nah you just when it's something on the
line and we talked about it before the
game in our pregame talk like you have
the opportunity to be first at something
this cup is no is not going anywhere I
mean it was a brilliant idea it went off
you know great and the way the games the
tournament games that were identified
were interwoven into the regular season
you really didn't have to go out of your
way to try to make it you know they
didn't separate uh the tournament games
from the regular season schedule was
interwoven in in so it was seamless and
then have a neutral site like Las Vegas
and to come here and uh really get to
enjoy this city it's a fabulous City
total NBA ready City and the Lakers we
felt like we had a leg up anyway wink
wink that's you know being it so close
to LA and it's just built-in home court
all the Lakers fans here so we just
wanted to make sure we came in and
played the right way and put on the show
and LeBron is at the top of that list to
force his will on the game both of those
games make sure we had the proper mental
focus and physical ability to close it
out yeah LeBron was saying post gave hey
it's just December this is great that we
won this but there are steps to still be
taken before April before the playoffs
what can you take from a win like this
and kind of apply towards the rest of
the season I mean just the the again the
three words I always used the
competitiveness the togetherness and
accountability um being able to play in
a highly intensified environment like
this with you know a trophy and a bag on
the line
um it was a mix between NCAA basketball
because if you lost you know it was that
was it uh but also the intensity of
playing formidable ball clubs you know I
know it was a lopsided win but New
Orleans is they're going you're going to
have to you're going to hear from New
Orleans by the time the playoffs get
here same with Indiana so it's a good
test for us for our guys to show that
they can come together gut out some
possessions and ultimately land the win
you know Darin we see some players you
see numbers but I want to dive deeper
Jared Vanderbilt has been out but uh
what he came and pressured 94t no points
tonight but I look at him as a guy that
might be that guy that get you guys over
the hump if he you know when and if when
he gets back healthy yeah once he
settles in man V I'm telling you man
he's the best Swiss army knife you could
possibly have on your team and you
mentioned it you know he he can impact
the game and so many a variety of ways
without even let alone scoring a field
goal but taking a field goal and so and
the beautiful thing about him he know
what his job is you know he's not
looking for touches he's going to dive
in from the weak side get us extra
possessions he's going to switch off on
bigs and Smalls he's going as you saw
him doing with with with with halberton
like picking up full court so that's the
biggest thing about our team guys are
falling into their roles and to have a
big moment like this I'll be it early in
the season but playing with the stakes
is kind of high and different things are
at stake and you see their competitive
spirit and everybody come together it's
a huge shot in the arm for us to
contining to develop that continuity and
that Rhythm to be successful Darin thank
you very much really appreciate
congratulations hey thank you guys
coaches getting paid too you know that
right yeah I'm getting nightmares cuz
I'm on this Baseline where I used to get
the Smitty the little Smitt this
Baseline is left side of the court I I
suffered that a couple of times
myself